3 2 ah non mais attention voilà
voilà matthieu delormeau et benjamin
castaldi sont là ils vont s'affronter
lors de trois épreuves trois vraies
épreuves de koh lanta
attention la première épreuve aller
simple c'est l'épreuve du tir à l'arc
c'est très simple et chéri vous allez
avoir trois flèches chacun vous allez
tire en même temps dans la cible
chernick ira la flèche la plus proche de
l'autre élimine une flèche de son
adversaire lâchez les plantes est quand
même allé planter quand même la côte est
même entièrement tournée break
pour la sorte en estrie à 00 h entrée
vous imaginez c'est normal à koh lanta
sans déconner 93,2 c'est castaldi un
poids pour gaza libre question mais oui
c'est ça avec l'armée l'a amené lui un
petit peu de pommade
oui attendez peut faire mieux valait
bien le voir tous les deux c'est la
deuxième épreuve vous mettez devant le
bac rouge
c'est une épreuve d'apnée vous allez
mettre la tête sous l'eau celui qui
restera le plus longtemps sous l'eau
gagnera la deuxième épreuve
je sors bien mathieu sur cette épreuve
je le connais il est très fort en apnée
bon moi je parle foot
un peu plus simple
c'est un grand fonds spéciaux des gens
je veux pas que ça triche je suis je
veux pas que battus au regard des gens
foncent vers la tête c'est franchement
attention on peut avoir un chrono si on
perd en régie parce qu'on a un regard à
taux plein malgré des belles fait des
blessés sans mal benjamin je ne sens pas
mathieu se sont très très large dans le
3e ronde
on dirait que ça fait une heure qui sont
dans l'eau soutient les invités à
s'abonner mec 30 secondes mathieu c'est
bon à tous et bon ami léo lâche le nom
d'allah il a été très bon mathieu c'est
une épreuve phare le colon tac nous
allons faire maintenant
l'épreuve de la boue daboub ou she
devant vous regardent et se trouve une
piscine de bon il a fait 23 ans qu'on
sait manier voudra mais la belle série
batman grand mère elle me défoncer vous
avez une minute pour vous couvrir le
corps debout et en m an maximum dans
votre saut n'ont pas notre souk et là il
ya un saut attention à la fin du temps
nous allons peser les sauts celui
qu'elles sont le plus lourd marquera
trois points et sera le grand gagnant de
notre koh lanta 3 2
dans nos mains attention voilà
voilà éliminé
allez pourrait faire plusieurs allers
retours oui c'est bien ben j c'est bien
basé mathieu
mais dans cinq
non pas d'en bref pas d'un moment dans
les ballons t-shirts
voilà les faits tous les bons merdy pas
il reste quinze secondes allez vite vous
avez le temps de faire un dernier râle
et retourne vite mathieu vite
bah ça va vite
vite je pense que ces machos qui est en
tête pour l'instant mais je suis pas sûr
benjamin castaldi 12 12 les douze kilos
voilà il faut que je reprenne son
souffle
je faut que je reprenne photo ap le prix
chez non vous avez fait des anciens de
tribus du fait 12 bat 12 à tout prix ce
n'est pas une belle variété née dedans
[Rires]
14 kg joly c'est matthieu delormeau
[Musique]